bueno buenas tardes
muy bueno hoy es el primer día de un
experimento así que vamos a hacer si es
un experimento en algunos sentidos
sí porque alá
he comenzado a trabajar aquí en
vancouver para ayudar a nuestro equipo
bueno
[Música]
el mercado de hispanohablantes y también
en el marketing digital en español
anna tiene mucha experiencia en el
marketing digital pero pero porque
estamos aquí en vancouver
donde no se habla español chino
[Risas]
soy yo
estoy en el first day a ver la entidad
el desvío el reto el reto es un gran
reto para mí
y nosotros no todos vamos a hacer vídeos
todos los dos semanas para ver para ver
el nivel de aprovechamiento mejor de
mejora bueno
durante esos vídeos estos esas esos
estas estos vídeos vamos también a
hablar sobre ciertos puntos de
aprendizaje de idiomas del inglés y
otras cosas que pueden ayudar
ellos bueno la gente que están
estudiando inglés
de disney de chavales
efe
in translation international comprensión
interna
en word
porque a mí me gusta aprender idiomas
aprendiendo
bueno
y la verdad que yo creo que soy un
ejemplo de muchos españoles que siempre
hemos querido aprender el inglés
yo empecé es muy pequeña con 8 años pero
siempre ha sido un reto y creo que
nuestros tres meses quiero poner mucho
foco y realmente aprovecharlos y ver una
evolución realmente real en mi inglés
la verdad que trabajando pues en una
empresa como lincoln es la oportunidad
de aprender el inglés para trabajar pero
también para el inglés para para
navidades en vancouver
vamos a terminar si esta entrevista aquí
bueno mucha suerte
[Música]